Piaget was very interested in how you
produce structures that enable you to
regulate yourself because you're like a
kind of a colony of strange sub animals
that have to figure out how to get along
so that you can sort of be one thing you
kind of learn that I would say between
the ages of 2 & 4 as you're being
socialized you know how erratic
two-year-olds are I mean they're a blast
and it's part because they were erratic
it's like they're unbelievably happy and
then they're unbelievably hungry and
then they're really hot and then they're
really upset and crying you know and
then they're really scared it's like and
all of that's just untrammeled and so
it's really fun to be around them
especially when they're happy because
they're so happy that it's just you know
you don't ever get to be that happy and
so it's nice to be around a two-year-old
because you can kind of feel that again
you know and a lot of what's the one of
the horrible things about being a parent
is that you spend a tremendous amount of
your time making your child less happy
and the reason for that is that positive
emotion is very impulsive you know and
you know because everybody says well you
should be happy it's like well no when
you're happy you're actually quite
stupid and so because happiness makes
you impulsive happiness makes happiness
says hey things are really good right
now get what you can while the getting's
good
and so as a like if you're hyper
optimistic manic will say it's like
every stock investment looks like a
really good stock investment it's like
you won't spend all your money because
look if there's those wonderful things
everywhere and you could do such great
things with them and then you know you
spend all your money and then you crash
and you think oh god my life's over you
know because I just I just spent all my
money on all this useless stuff but and
it's all under the grip of impulsive
positive emotion you know and so when
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settle down it isn't because
they're making a lot of noise being in
pain it's because they're running around
like wild baboons having a blast and
disrupting things like mad you know and
so how you got kids you got to settle
down you know like quit having so much
fun and it's it's kind of awful it's
that you do that but but you do and
that's because
the emotions and the motivations have to
be brought in to like a relationship
with one another within the person so
that you know one thing I remember with
my son who is quite he's quite
disagreeable by temperament which is
actually a good thing as far as I'm
concerned although it brings its own
challenges and so with my daughter when
she was misbehaving
she was pretty agreeable and you know if
she was misbehaving I could basically
just look at her and then she'd quit you
know but my son it was like now that was
just nothing you're looking at me it's
like no that's just not going to go
anywhere man and so then I'd like tell
him to stop and that really wasn't
having much of an effect either he just
sort of made me laugh or run away or
whatever I mean he was a tough little
rat and you know what I would do with
him is he would be doing something and
I'd interfere and he'd get upset and you
know angry and so then I get him to sit
on the steps and I had told him this is
when he was about to I said look you're
gonna sit on the steps that's timeout
you're going to sit on the steps until
you've got control of yourself and you
can come back and be and play the family
game again I basically said be a
civilized human being and then you're
welcome again and so he'd sit on the
steps it was so interesting to watch
because he was just enraged he'd sit
there like have you ever seen a
two-year-old have a temper tantrum
it's really quite the bloody phenomena
if you ever saw an adult do that you'd
like you'd call 911
11 11 I God but I've seen adults do that
you know because people say with
borderline personality disorder we'll
have temper tantrums and it's like man
you want to be about 30 feet away from
that person that's for sure it's really
but in kids it's like well first of all
they're only this long so how much
trouble can they really cause but it's
like you know they're just completely
gone they're like on the floor their
face is red
they're just serious like way more
furious than you ever get if you're even
vaguely socialized they're just outraged
and they're kicking and hitting the
ground and like it's like a little
epileptic fit of anger you know they're
completely controlled by their rage and
we took care of one kid for a while who
he was out actually a pushover that kid
get him to behave by you know kind of
shaking your finger at him but his
mother thought he was really tough
because he had her food he had her
figured out and one of the things he
would do is have a temper tantrum and
during the temper tantrum he would hold
his bloody breath until he turned blue
it's like try that like you know well
that's your homework go home and go home
and have a temper tantrum and while
you're doing it hold your breath until
you actually turn blue it's like you
won't be able to do it you don't have
the willpower of a two-year-old that's
for sure that little varmint man he just
have a fit then he'd hold his breath and
then he turned blue it was like wow
that's that's amazing and we would just
like let him do it you know he'd turned
blue and everybody would be gone and
he'd come out of it you know and it
didn't work so he just quit doing it I
think he did it like twice and he
figured out oh well that's a lot of work
for a very little outcome and you know
it's not like two-year-olds are stupid
they're they're not stupid they're
probably smarter than you but they're
not civilized by any stretch of the
imagination and so anyways back to my
son I put him on the steps and he'd be
like oh just like enraged and and trying
to get himself together you know and I'd
wait up I got a strict rule which was as
soon as you're done you're welcome again
so it's completely under your control
you you get yourself calm down you come
and talk to me again if you're calm
enough so I like you then you're welcome
back in the family no grudge nothing and
so it's harder than you think
like people think they like their kids
it's like don't be thinking that they're
hard to like their little monsters and
they're very very pushy and provocative
and so lots of parents do not like their
children and they do terrible things to
them their whole life so it's no joke
and it's a very common and you know that
was Freud's observation fundamental
observation that a lot of
psychopathology is rooted in the family
and you can be sure of that you know
when when you hear about some mother
who's done something terrible to her
child which happens reasonably
frequently you know perfectly well that
she has a very terrible capacity to
discipline the child's just provoked her
and provoked her and provoked her and
provoked her and provoked her and it
just happens to be a day where her new
boyfriend left and she's quite hungover
and she got fired and it's like that's
the wrong day to provoke her and then
she does something that is not good and
you read about it and you think well how
could that happen
how could anyone do that well that's how
they do it and so and kids are very
provocative just like little chimps
chimps will the adolescents will like
throw little pebbles and sticks out the
sleeping larger males and Bund them and
that teasing which it is that teasing
turns into full-fledged
dominance challenged behavior once the
adolescent males get big enough to do it
and so when you're being provoked by a
child which they provoke kill time
they're trying to figure out well just
where are you exactly what happens if I
do this what happens if I do this you
know and how else are they going to
figure it out anyways he'd sit on the
steps and just just enraged and trying
to control himself and I'd watch that
and then you know I come back after
about two minutes or whatever and he'd
still be ER I'd say well are you know
have you got yourself under control are
you ready get off the steps go no not
yet
and then you know he'd get himself under
control and then he'd come back and you
know he'd be contrite and then I would
like him right away you know if you go
to watch that you know because you don't
like being dominated by a two-year-old
no one does and so if the child hasn't
mastered himself and started to act in
accordance with the prevailing social
norms you won't like them while you
think oh yeah I will because you know
I'm a good person like no you won't see
and know you're not a good person so
don't be thinking about that at all just
not true so when he was contrite then
he'd come and then you know we just go
on like nothing had happened because
that's what you want to do right as soon
as you get compliance especially if the
compliance is in the best interest of
the child you want to reward it
instantly right that's the right thing
to do because so then and and you could
just see him gaining control over
himself and so really what was happening
is his in his mind in his brain will say
there was a war between the psyche the
ego that was starting to become
integrated you know and starting to
become a content
you as person an identity and it's
fragile in two-year-olds and it can be
disrupted all the time and it is that's
why they're so hyper emotional it's
fragile that little Eagle and it doesn't
have a lot of power and so what you want
to do is reward it when it wins you know
it's when it when he gets control over
the underlying motivations you want to
say hey good work man good work kid you
did it you know you got yourself under
control way to be and the kids really
happy about that because it's actually
not that much fun to have a temper
tantrum it's exhausting you know it
takes you over